[Music]
the cfar israeli global scholars program
has accelerated my career by introducing
me to scholars from diverse disciplines
all over the world who share many of my
challenges but also have inspired me to
think about my research in new ways
these meetings are often like who's who
in the field and what's been very
valuable for me is that a lot of these
international cfar fellows or cfr global
scholars have actually been the most
incisive critics of my work and that
kind of opportunity to engage with them
in a very friendly manner helps a lot
the unrestricted funds that i received
as a cfar israeli global scholar was
really valuable to me it allowed me to
pursue a lot of high-risk directions
that i wouldn't be
able to pursue otherwise at the stage of
my career the mentorship opportunities
are incredible you are placed in contact
with luminaries in your field who will
actually take an interest in your case
and help you think about how to guide
your research to maximum impact
[Music]